-Jeanne Moreau
qui vient d'obtenir l'Oscar
de la meilleure actrice française,
a accepté de se prêter au "Jeu
"de la vérité".
La vedette de "La bonne soupe",
de "La chatte sur un toit brûlant",
"Les amants",
et qui sera demain dans
"Les liaisons dangereuses",
interprète généralement
à la scène et à l'écran
des rôles qui sont
à la limite de l'audace.
Audace sentimentale, audace de
caractère, audace des situations.
On imagine mal comment
on pourrait être plus audacieux
sans passé la mesure.
Pirandello a écrit l'histoire
d'une vedette
qui aime un homme
lequel ne peut accepter
que cette femme
se donne en pâture au public.
Nous voulons savoir
si cette situation
n'était pas sans dommage pour
la vie privée de Jeanne Moreau.
Permettez-moi
de vous tendre ce miroir
qui sera le symbole
de ce "Jeu de la vérité".
D'abord, j'aimerais vous demander
si vous aimez votre visage,
votre silhouette.
-Non.
-Vous n'avez jamais aimé ?
Je me suis habituée,
mais je ne peux pas dire que j'ai
un goût particulier pour mon visage
ou ma silhouette.
-Etes-vous, selon vous, de ce
qu'on appelle, "sexy" ?
-Je ne peux pas dire que...
Je pense que je le sois.
Mais j'ai été obligée
d'accepter ce jugement,
parce que...
on me l'a fait comprendre.
Sexy n'est peut-être pas exactement
le mot. Je crois que je plais.
Le fait d'avoir du succès,
ça signifie que je plais.
-N'êtes-vous pas gênée
par le fait
que la plupart de vos attitudes
physiques, de vos réflexes,
de vos tics les plus légers,
sont connus par des millions
de personnes, et surtout
par ceux de votre entourage ?
-Bien sûr, cela est gênant,
car vous m'en parlez.
Je vous avoue sincèrement que je
n'y ai pas pensé de cette façon.
Et surtout, j'ai l'impression que,
étant une comédienne,
quand j'interprète un personnage,
ces expressions
qui me sont particulières,
je les attribue à un personnage.
Alors, j'ai l'impression
que dans ma vie courante,
ces expressions sont différentes,
je me trompe peut-être.
-Sûrement.
Le désir des hommes,
vos admirateurs à l'écran,
vous gêne dans la vie ?
-Non.
Je n'ai jamais été soumise à
certaine situation irrespectueuse.
Même à la suite
de la projection des "Amants",
je n'ai pas reçu de lettre
ayant un ton
que j'aurais pu trouver injurieux,
au contraire.
-Excusez-moi d'insister, mais...
Quand vous mimez à l'écran,
vous avez une certaine façon
de prendre le visage d'un homme,
de l'étreindre, de l'embrasser,
qui vous est très particulière,
que l'on retrouve
dans tout vos films.
Est-ce que dans la vie,
ces mêmes situations,
quand vous les ressentez
intensément,
ne sont pas diminués
d'une partie de leur vérité,
de leur qualité, par le fait
qu'à l'écran et à la scène,
vous avez tenu les mêmes rôles ?
-Ce n'est pas à moi
qui faudrait poser cette question.
Car j'ai l'impression d'être toute
différente dans ma vie privée.
Et cette situation passionnelle
qui est provoquée sur un plateau
de cinéma ou de théâtre,
pour moi est très douloureuse
et difficile.
Je n'ai pas l'impression
d'être spontanée.
Tout cela est une question
d'imagination et de mémoire.
C'est ça jouer la comédie,
je crois.
-Vous n'avez pas l'impression
de jouer dans la vie la comédie ?
-Non.
J'aurais peut-être cette impression
si quelqu'un me disait :
"J'ai déjà vu cette expression
quelque part."
-Ca vous ai déjà arrivé
de vous arrêter brusquement
au moment où vous alliez
prononcé un mot,
à un être aimé, par exemple,
parce que c'était justement
le mot d'un rôle ?
-Non, ça ne m'est pas arrivée.
Ca peut arriver aussi bien à des
gens qui ne jouent pas à la comédie,
parce que les mots
sont toujours les mêmes,
les êtres changent quelques fois,
et les situations sont les mêmes.
Il y a des femmes à qui il est
arrivé de dire les mêmes phrases
à des hommes différents.
-Vous pourriez aimer une vedette
et croire à son amour ?
-Je ne pense pas que je pourrais
aimer un acteur.
-Pourquoi ?
-Je ne sais pas.
Je trouve que c'est un métier
difficile à accepter pour une femme,
mais pour un homme c'est une
situation encore plus particulière.
Alors, il faut des qualités
de féminité, d’ambiguïté,
qui ne sont pas des qualités
particulièrement masculines.
Et un homme qui est comme ça
n'est pas un homme véritable.
-C'est une condamnation ?
-Je ne sais pas.
-Vous pourriez être autre chose ?
-Oui.
-Quoi ?
-Etre une femme, simplement.
-Vous avez déjà songé à renoncer
à votre carrière ?
Vous vous êtes
fixée une date ?
-Oui.
Je me suis fixée 2 dates,
je peux vous le dire.
Quand j'ai commencé à travailler,
je me suis donnée 10 ans
pour arriver à être quelque chose
ou quelqu'un qui me ressemble.
Et ces 10 ans sont écoulés.
-Vous avez réussi ?
-Oui.
Et maintenant
je me donne encore 10 ans.
-Peut-on encore pendant 10 ans
jouer le jeu que vous avez joué
sans être autre chose que soi-même,
sans être brusquement un double
et avoir des comptes à rendre
à ce double ?
-Oui. Peut-être, oui.
-Etes-vous sûre maintenant
que si vous choisissiez de renoncer
vous le pourriez réellement ?
A cette seconde, j'en doute.
J'ai l'impression que l'actrice
commande et que la femme doit obéir.
-La situation ici est particulière,
car cet interview n'a pas été
préparé, il est improvisé.
Je suis quand même dans des éléments
qui ressemblent à ce que je connais,
les projecteurs, les caméras,
les questions précises.
Et vous posez ces questions
à Jeanne Moreau...
Alors je suis tiraillée, je ne suis
pas dans une situation véritable.
-C'est une certaine comédie ?
-Jusqu'à un certain point, oui.
-Si c'est un proche qui vous pose
ces questions, ça serait différent.
-Oui.
-Mais le problème serait le même,
car vous aimez ces projecteurs,
vous vivez avec ces caméras.
Vous auriez à résoudre
la même équation.
-Je vous assure que
je pourrais m'en passer.
-Je crois qu'on peut se séparer
de cette certitude. Merci.